we are working toward secure sustainable
competitive and affordable energy for
every European and the world needs to
limit at the same time the effects of
climate change and shift to more
sustainable source of energy we reach
the general approach on
intergovernmental agreements between
member states and third countries when
individual EU countries negotiates
energy agreements with non-eu countries
these agreements must comply with EU law
the North Sea countries and the
Commission signs a political declaration
to work together to develop more north
sea wind farms make them more efficient
and make them cheaper to build and to
run in other areas we also had a
important discussion mainly on the
security of gas supply regulation and
the bad presidency highlighted the
importance of regional cooperation
solidarity and transparency as the core
principles of that propulsion accounts
were adopted a general approach on a
draft directive concerning the
recognition of professional
qualifications in inland navigation we
also reached an agreement on for
mandates for the Commission to start
negotiations on the establishment of
comprehensive air transport agreements
with a saiyan with guitar with the
United Arab Emirates and with Turkey we
discussed the EU contribution to the
ongoing talks in ICAO on a global market
based measure to tackle co2 emissions
from international aviation we didn't
get the maximum length for negotiations
as we wanted but we settled I mean of
course we accepted the decision of the
council and we will try to do our best
to finish the negotiations within the
specified periods which is three and
four years we announced three proposals
adopted by the commission yesterday to
simplify and improve rules in this area
we believe that this is really important
for passenger safety European passengers
travel more and more
especially for pleasure to inter ism and
we found we found it very important that
after 15 years we introduced new steps
in this area